[Music]
all right so uh back in I believe it was
December around 6:30 a.m. in front of
The Farmhouse Fraternity in Stillwater
Oklahoma there was a steer or a longhorn
found dead oh no all right a have you
seen a Longhorn in real life I have not
have you dude the pictures the Longhorns
are so big I don't even see that coming
real dude the pictures them
nice good Joe they're big they're huge
so this was a you know one of those
Twisted messages that was sent uh to the
Cowboys ahead of their big 12
Championship football game against the
Texas Longhorns oh sure alsoo it was
like one of those school things like
it's a prank bro but they killed an
animal cruel didn't they used to do that
like in the' 70s or some [__] yeah
that's like some rural [__] yeah it's
like you're cougar so they go to the
mountains and they found a cougar and
they killed it and like leave it in the
school lot and be like we got you I
don't want to get race involved it does
sound like a white activity it is man
college football is very serious the
body of the animal was discovered with
its stomach cut open and on its side
somebody had written basically F FH or
whatever that's also not as big of a
deal in those communities because for us
it would be really weird but for them
somebody that they know Works in that
field of like Butchery you kill this one
yeah it's like oh we'll just get grab a
pig from this dude's place yeah that's
[__] yeah it's probably not that far
of a of a throw for them not far but it
is still like [__] weird that's wild
yeah like you a dead animal for the sake
of this message for what [__] college
football dude you're not barbecue them
though if they barbecue and everyone
eats them then maybe that's okay cuz I
would see that as a gifting the other
team I I would see that as a gift I'd
just be like oh free tuna maybe somebody
will cut poke it every night yo imagine
they doing that with like a blue tuna
[__] a prank that'd be tight but like
half Frozen still so you're kind of like
ooh usable but honestly if you if
someone drops up blue Fant Tuna on your
front step like that you wouldn't be
that mad that's like $20,000 worth of
could be 100 Grand but a cow is just
like aesthetically is just like oh
that's like way more gruesome but and
it's like three grand yeah I don't know
maybe more a full steer I think it's
like under 10 it's got to be like five
grand or something damn really I'm
throwing out numbers guys I watched this
guy he did half of a cow I saw a photo
yeah he and he was talking about how
this shit's going to feed his family for
like 150 days they it comes to you like
he goes we get half a steer and then he
was showing us his [__] box and I
don't know this guy he was showing me on
the reels right and it's not that
expensive uh it like according to the
USDA a young beef animal ready for
Slaughter currently sells around 1,100
to 1250 oh wow that's cheap so under 2
Grand I was way off a young one though
so that means not a lot of meat you're
talking about prime prime Slaughter they
slaughter him young I don't have no idea
yeah that's a choice
cow that's a choice you're not talking
about Choice yeah I'm talking about
maybe wagu yeah yeah marbled very mared
it's wag imagine doing that with a wag
you cow you could never you want to send
you want to send a real
message get that Australian wagy five
cows I eat so much steak and I'm like
why don't I just do that order half
leave it in the freezer and I don't have
to go to the steak because you don't eat
it every meal like that's part of why
you like certain things I think I could
eat steak almost every day a lot dude I
eat a lot of steak how much red meat do
you guys eat I eat a lot of red meat if
I don't eat if I don't eat it daily I
start to feel like a
[__] as long as it's pretty just go
down like you're not eat chicken or fish
too much I literally feel weaker I'm
like oh [__] really what wonder I didn't
get that I got some homies sometimes
that like I got to eat like chicken fish
I've been eating too much red meat and
I'm like mother I eat red meat right now
people give [__] about red meat but it's
like you get so much you get so much B
vitamins and micronutrients in in red
meat than you do with uh like chicken or
and fish but even with with beef I think
the one thing is like oh it's like fatty
Cuts but as long as you're not eating
fatty Cuts all the time you're fine but
I would want to
be a low riye with your sirloin that's
nice even even with bodybuilding like
when you're like starting to really dial
in the last couple of weeks and it's
just chicken and broccoli or like fish
and like asparagus like where you're
eating like 1,000 calories a day they
still recommend to have one meal of red
meat per week just to kind of re reusten
your your body a little bit cuz you're
so Z too lean with for me it's just a
taste like that there's nothing that
replaces the taste of beef that on fire
yeah it's got to be on fire it's just
don't people who boil beef what the [__]
is wrong with you you like tartar though
you like tartar
is nice theore well yeah in the
uh Bop but the with the with the raw
beef that's good what is that oh they
yeah I've had that raw beef beeing Bo
yeah it's like I ordered it on accident
one day cuz I didn't know saw in a photo
I don't even know if it's Bing Bob but
it's like that style the stone you it's
not Stone it's just like is it with like
rice and stuff yeah it's like rice
chopped vegetables sliced thin [__]
all me yeah yeah yeah and then I was
like that shit's [__] fire and they
the Koreans do that and then um the
koream pear it's like a nice bite Fant
crunch with the soft the egg yolk fire
so good the Asian let's get Korean
barbecue oh dude oh bro we I know a spot
let's go for dinner we went to we went
to this uh the chubby cattle place and
they do they do A5 they do A5 W like
well it's not all A5 but it's all wag
you beef but like you know after you eat
a bunch of it you're like I'm going to
have a heart attack in like 5 minutes
nope no dude bro it's it's FB I don't
want to a that felt so good I don't I
don't want to one up you right now but I
ate uh this much wagu with my friends
yeah me too I had this much I think it
was like three grand it was three grand
okay for this much wagu 3500 we ate it
for every [__] day that three of my
friends puked I was able to go for day
four but after that I can't eat another
piece of wagu like till this day if if
they're like we have wagu ooh and I'm
all eating it I'm all I had enough is it
because it's more white than red was it
too buttery like the yeah like the it's
like eating grilled butter you're a
bunch of Satur [__] good though it's
meant to be just small doses yeah it's
like even Toro like like everyone goes
ah [__] Toro up and I'm two or three
pieces maybe I think it's
how you pair it though like if you have
if you have like a really nice fatty cut
of like wagu and then at that at chubby
cattle they give you some pineapple
slices bro oh nice Al to rinse her
palette a little bit let me tell you
about pineapple and pineapple cinnamon
grilled just [__] I can't compete with
cinnamon let's [__] him
up a little lettuce WRA can you guys eat
grilled pizza every
day what's grilled pizza I could eat
pizza every day so just I think I could
yeah I was just thinking about what's
like the fattiest [__] and that's like
all that cheese you know oh like what's
oh I see what you mean like I could
probably eat pizza every dayza pretty
[__] good but I feel sick after yeah
it gets me like acid I eat french fries
every day tomatoes and the cheese I
could eat yaku every meal fries oh you
like yukaku yeah Toro beef beastro
hanger IAT that hang I mean give it to a
room full of Asians who sees a animal
Slaughter as a prank and go hungry man
I'm [__] hungry
because we're
efficient yeah we can't waste that meat
you know what's funny they were trying
to do some like like animal abuse
propaganda [__] in my college they're
like this is what they do to get Fu gu
and this is what a butcher thing looks
like and I was looking at it and I'm all
damn bro I want steak now man none of
that [__] [__] affected me that's how
suiz me was I got McDonald's right away
exactly in my health class we watch
super siiz me and like all the kids vow
to never eat it I'm like yo I want some
McDonald's I saw that full throw up in
the in the in the movie where he's like
oh this is whatever me had another
Double D when he threw out I threw up
out the window I was like man you
[__] [__] and you're like bro you
trying to get you trying to be unhealthy
right now you sh easily I can eat
McDonald's every [__] and it came out
later that dude like failed drug test
and [__] during that time what kind of
drug test on drugs and [__] oh was he oh
the munchies it makes McDonald's face
evenly you probably need the munchies
for that to eat McDonald's every day you
need some munchies bro oh I don't know
if I could do that I could eat
McDonald's day for a while McDonald's
every day you got to really strategize
how much you for a month I can do it for
a month no way I feel like you have a
strong no you got to so you do like you
just got to change the meats around you
go fish some chicken some beef I think I
can eat it parfait today I can eat it
for the taste but just to see yourself
get that fat is pretty rough I've seen
myself get pretty
fat you're like I kind of like it I feel
like you feel pretty exp I feel like we
have like reverse body dysmorphia where
I'm like pretty [__] handsome you
know and then like I'm like yeah you are
I'm like I'm always looking at the
positive of like even though I have this
little bump I'm still [__] strong you
know and I feel like me Bart and David
we egged each other on there was a time
when all three of us got fat
together and then none of us that's cool
nah it was just just kept going we just
kept going and I think we all have that
where we look in the mirror and go oh
that's funny but at the same time man I
have Elite genetics cuz I'm still strong
compared to other people that would have
been even more fatter yeah that's
true